My name is Kathy Pham and I am a Harvard
Berkman Klein Fellow for the 2017-2018
year. Having worked with both a
large tech company, as well as within the
federal government, I constantly think
about how do we build products that are
responsible and ethical and take into
account our users? Another focus is the
intersection of government and technology.
How do we get policy folks interested in,
but also understanding technology, as
well as getting technologists, whether
they're engineers, or product managers, or
designers, interested in public service
or working in the federal government. In
my early days as a software engineer the
topics around users and the user
experience of something, or even the
broader social impact of what we build
wasn't always there, either. One of the
things that has come up here at
Berkman is attacking it from the
curricula level of really teaching our
computer scientists and engineers how to
critically think about the effects in
the long term, or even short term effects,
of what we build. Think about some of
the implications of collecting data.
Think about what happens when the data is
stored long term. Think about how
something can be misused or not used the
way we intended for it to be used.
What can we do in the policy space that
makes sense? You know, it gets tricky
because we we get into the free speech
realm of we don't want to restrict the
ability to build products or people's
freedom of speech on different platforms,
but what is the responsibility of tech
companies in looking at their users? How
can we use technology to really provide
better government services for people,
people who can't go in-person to
different government service locations
to get care, whether they're veterans, or
people who need to get services. How can
we use technology to really make their
lives a lot better? I constantly think,
I'm very excited about different ways
that technology can be used to provide
care services to maybe our most
vulnerable populations or people who
need help the most.